I think this is an appropriate moment to try and
summarize some of the basic concepts behind
the course, and
actually very much leading on from what
Miroslav, and Doug have
just been saying.
And this starts with a
a claim, which is that
to understand the modern world, you have to
be faith-literate.
You have to understand
the role of faith.
And it is built on
what I'm going to call facts, or certain facts,
or certain, I would say,
clear
and distinguishable
elements of reality about the modern world.
Globalization
is growing as a phenomenon,
and it is driven by people,
and it is constantly
pushing the world together.
There is nowhere-- I
travel extensively-- there is nowhere I go
in the world today
where it is not
obvious that
the impact of globalization is changing,
not merely the economies, but the societies
of those countries.
The other thing which, until a few years
ago,
would have been
a fact that people would have questioned, is that
faith is not diminishing-- it is in fact growing.
Now it is not growing everywhere,
and you could argue that in Europe and in some
parts of the West it is diminishing.
Somewhat, at least.
But it is nonetheless
growing worldwide,
and not simply within the religion of Islam.
Christianity is a great phenomenon in China.
What comes out of these--
these facts are, then,
other realities.
The interaction between people
is of a different
nature
as a result
of globalization pushing people together. Now
what Miroslav was talking about--
that the encounter between two is really between four,
is really between six, which I was
a trifle confused about to begin with, but that
you explained and now I understand exactly
what you mean--
actually it's a very important point, because
if you're
with somebody who's from the same village in
Europe, the same faith and the same color
and the same ethnic background,
there're a whole series of things that you assume
that you don't have to find out about, you just--
it's very natural to you.
You put in
a whole lot of difference, diversity-- that
is then a different type of encounter--
an encounter obviously with more
dimensions. So that interaction
between people
through globalization,
through people of--
interaction between
people of different faiths and cultures
is qualitatively
far more
profound to understand and to cope with
than in previous times.
It is also correct
that
people's faith
can be, as
we said right in the beginning, it can be a
source of
identity, and is a source of identity, for sure--
can be a source of identity and opposition
in contradiction to others--
can therefore result in faith
giving rise to conflict,
which it does, and we saw
the role of religion
is dominant in probably a majority of conflicts
now in the world.
But also,
faith can give rise to good works;
that is plainly true
as well.
At the same time,
there are
differences between faiths, and also--
as Doug was just saying-- there is some
point at which
there seems to be
a rapprochement
of values between the different faiths.
We're just dealing with facts now; these are the
things that go to make up this
matrix of-- what I would call the matrix
of realities around these issues to do with faith and
globalization.
There are also -- this is another the thing
that is happening in the world at the moment--
there are debates within each state.
So one of the things that is
really
mistaken is to talk about
a faith as if there is a certain
dominant view within that faith of how it
sees the world. Actually, you look at any
major faith today,
there is plainly a traditional and a modernizing
tendency;
there is a reaching out tendency and a
reaching in tendency--
this is true within
virtually all faiths, and
if you take debates of agenda--
just take debates over gay rights--
you can have people of the same faith reaching
diametrically different conclusions on these issues.
But faith will be the prism within which
many of these issues are discussed and debated.
Here's something else that I think is important:
is that faith communities themselves-- they're also
evolving.
Now they're evolving off in different directions.
And you can get
even contradictory directions.
But that is also happening.
So my sort of stopping point is:
you need to be
faith-literate.
Why? Because
globalization is pushing people together,
the world of faith is growing,
the interplay between people then becomes
more important,
faith can be a force for good-- it can be a
force for bad--
there are clearly
common areas within--
between faiths, there are major differences--
but also, there is this
evolution within the faith community
where there are differences between
people as to what they think
within the same faith-- intra-faith--
and the faith communities themselves are
evolving.
So what this means, in my view, and one of
the things-- 'cause
all the way through, what I'm trying to think of is what are
the practical consequences
for policy, for thought, as a result of
this?
What is obvious is that this relationship between
the world of faith and the world of globalization,
is an important part of understanding the
modern world and
having
a relationship that is positive between those
two is an important part of making the modern
world work.
Now one of the
practical consequences out of this, I think,
is that we need
to develop
actually, a far greater
understanding of what these-- how these
different forces are developing,
and this is not a religious question.
One of the reasons why this course is a--
is a collaboration
between the School of Management and the School
of Divinity is precisely because we recognize this
is not just a religious question; it has major
social, economic, and political
consequences.
So the question that we then
ask, arising out of this, is--
okay, so
how do we make--
how do we make this world work?
And
I would suggest that the following is essential
if we want to make it work--
here are five points I'll make briefly.
The first is, we need knowledge.
We need to have knowledge.
Knowledge is essential.
Knowledge is good in itself--
an explanation-- knowing--
being able to understand the other person.
This is a central part of it.
So one major aspect of what we have to do
is to make sure that people have the
ability and capacity
and opportunity
to learn.
Ignorance, to fear, to conflict
is one very obvious
train of happenstance.
Understanding,
acceptance, peace is another.
So. The fact that you know about the other person,
the fact that you understand where they
come from, the fact that you have some
concept in your mind of their cultural background--
doesn't mean to say you get on, but
it's obviously a help and I would say that knowledge
is essential.
Essential
at the level of leaders and nations,
which is why things like--
this concept that Turkey and Spain launched
about the alliance of civilizations, which
is very much-- obviously a sort of counterpoint
to the Huntington thesis--
it's important at that level.
It is important to the level of action and
I
agree with what
Doug is saying, and actually the discussion with
Rick about
hand to heart to head came out of discussions
we had had with Rick and with others,
which is that if you start with action,
then you're more likely to get people
to interact together
without a lot of complicating theological
questions where you immediately highlight
the differences between people.
So for example one part of what we do in
in the foundation is to try and get people
to work together on the anti-malaria campaign.
However--
and this may seem strange from me since I come
from the world of the sort of--
it's supposed to be the world of practice, in
politics,
and you guys come from the world of academia--
I also think, though, that
education--
not just in the terms of the exchange of information,
but in the academic sense-- is an important
part of this. I think we need to understand
some of the phenomena that are working here;
I think we have to have a far greater
ability both in research, empirical
evidence, and data to try and work out what
are these different
strands that are going on
within the world today.
And so when I say, first point is knowledge
is essential,
I think there's a massive amount
that we've still got to accomplish
in trying to make that knowledge as deep
and as--
as deep and as
comprehensive
as it needs to be.
The second thing-- so that's the first thing:
how do we make this world of
faith and globalization work? Knowledge. The second
is this:
you do need to acknowledge, in any society,
if you're going to have
a society where there is harmony between faiths--
there's got to be some common space and some
common rules of engagement.
And this is in a sense what we were talking
with Nick
last week about.
You have to accept that different faiths have an
equal right to speak;
you have to accept that actually
the secular world and the faith world also
have equal rights to speak;
you have to have some rules of engagement for
this.
I think you need--
as we were saying last week-- you need
some civility in the nature of the debate,
and you also need
countries and societies that are of different
faiths and different cultures--
they've got to have some
common space where people congregate
and are prepared to say,
"This is what we share in common,
and this is
an important part also of our identity."
We don't give up our faith identity,
but, you know, just as in America when
the flag is there, people rise to salute
the flag, and that is what you do whatever
your faith, whatever your color, whatever your
background--
that is a unifying force.
Actually
this is something that is
can be seen
as patriotism, and of course it is,
but actually there's something else that's
really important about that;
it's an indication that at this point and
in this space, everyone comes together.
And I think that's a critical part;
I think it's a critical part of the rules of engagement
for a multi-faith society.
But I think you need that common space and you need
those common rules of engagement.
I think thirdly that
in practice
what this then means
is an attitude
that is
what I would call open rather than closed.
And what's more, it should be a goal
of public policy
to encourage or facilitate that openness.
There's an interesting
side consequence of this,
which is
it actually has an impact
on globalization as well-- on
your economic policy.
Because it's very hard
to have a society that is open
in terms of faith, in terms of culture, in terms of
background,
if it's closed economically.
So there is a link, in fact, between
the idea that in the modern world
human capital is essential,
that human capital should be
on the basis
of
the equal dignity of each human being
and actually a successful economy,
I hope, where people are recognizing that they
live in a world
in which there's going to be
trade between nations and exchange of
intellectual,
human, and financial capital.
And actually, one of the reasons why
protectionism, in my view, is not a good response
in today's world is
partly because if you take that closed economic
attitude, it actually becomes quite hard to have
an open
attitude to
people of different faiths
and backgrounds within society.
So, in practice, it requires an open
and not a closed attitude-- that should
be a goal of public policy--
and here's one other thing which I think is really
important--
is that if you have that open attitude,
then I think
it doesn't really work
unless
it comes on the basis of that
openness being there available
for all and not simply for a few.
So there is something universal
about that
for it to work.
Now, fourthly,
even if you believe you have an exclusive
truth-- faith truth--
you've still got to be in support of
an inclusive society.
This is a point that Miroslav has often made and
I think it's
worth just spending a moment on, which is that
what he says, in essence-- as I understand it-- is this: that
if you have a faith
and--
let's see--
you're a Christian, you believe in salvation
through Jesus Christ--
you cannot at a certain point--
I mean that is what you believe is the
truth--
you cannot at a certain point say, "Well,
but I think you who don't believe that
have equal validity, because--
I mean, obviously that's
the whole essence of your belief.
And so Miroslav, I think, has drawn a distinction between,
as it were,
exclusivity in terms of,
"This is my truth, my faith truth that I believe in,"
and then
using that exclusivity in terms of shutting
out the other person, right?
And I think that is true, but I also think
something else
that is interesting about the way globalization
interplays with
faith
is that
as that--
as that knowledge deepens,
and as
you learn
to inhabit freely that common space,
and as that produces what I would say is a kind of
more open attitude,
I think
faith also evolves in that process.
So that--
so that
yes, you still believe
in your own faith
but your
openness to someone of another faith
is more than just accepting that they have
that faith
and that they believe it's valid.
You also start to accept their spiritual
sincerity, right,
even if you don't necessarily accept their truth
claim.
And that's quite important,
and you were quoting St. Paul
earlier-- the extraordinary thing about the early Christian church
was St. Paul
going out and saying, "This is a message that
I have for
Greek as well as Jew"-- that
that this is, as it were, a message that is
universal and not simply restricted
to the Jewish people.
When you come to Islam,
the whole point about what the Prophet was
saying was a way actually to push it even
broader
than, up to then, either the Jewish faith or
the Christian faith had acknowledged.
My point is simply this:
that the fourth thing that I think you require
for
this world of faith and globalization
to work--
is that at least
you--
even if you believe you have the exclusive
truth, you've got to want an inclusive society.
But I also think that
you need to accept
that there is a level of respect
that you have for the person of a different faith
that is more than simply accepting as a
fact that they have a different faith,
but you also accept the sincerity with which
they hold that faith, and that
some good can come out of it.
In other words-- you know, when I
engage with somebody
of a different faith who's engaged with us
in our projects-- for example in Africa, on the
anti-malaria campaign, we work with--
I mean, primarily, actually
with Jews and Muslims as well as Christians,
although actually there are
Hindus involved
in it as well, but--
when I see what a
difference,
let's say,
somebody of
the Jewish faith-- what a difference their faith
makes
to them and their actions,
it's more than, for me, simply,
"Well, I accept that they happen to feel very strongly,
and I'm prepared to accept that reality."
I'm actually accepting something more than
that.
I'm accepting
that there is a
sincerity about their view,
and
a motivation as a result of that for them
to do good that
sits alongside, if you like, the issue to do
with who is right and wrong in a faith sense.
It sits alongside it quite powerfully.
You what I mean?
So it's a--
and this is what I think is fascinating
about the way the world then develops, because
the-- yes, you keep your own religious faith, and
you keep that strongly,
but your very open to the other
and you're working alongside them and you're understanding
why it is that they are as they are--
also
changes your own sense
of what faith
is about. It doesn't
change your own belief,
but it does let you acknowledge someone of
a different belief, I think in a far more profound
way
than simply accepting as a matter of fact
they've got a different faith.
And that's where you move, I think,
from tolerance to respect--
which is a very, very important part of the
journey.
And the final thing
is this--
and here is where I think
the debate is, in a sense,
at its most
interesting-- because
we've really discussed this very often,
for obvious reasons,
in the context of what
in an era of globalization, how do you make
religious faith end up as a source of
coexistence and not
conflict. So we really--
we've really looked at
the issue of faith
more in terms of,
is it a force for good or ill in faith terms,
or in social terms.
There's something else, though, that is
really interesting--
which is that globalization
is a force,
but if it is to be welcomed,
it needs for the benefits of that
globalization
to be shared,
for the opportunities
not to be restricted,
and globalization without values
governing it and underpinning it--
globalization is less likely
to be accepted,
less likely to be successful,
and actually less likely to work,
because if it's not accepted,
and it's not successful,
globalization itself can become
a force
that is-- that can produce conflict
or ill.
And therefore, that's why therefore what is interesting
about the role
of faith and why
people thought maybe you'd squeeze faith out
of society
as economic prosperity advanced.
Why hasn't it happened, in the end?
It hasn't happened because of something
very deep within people
that says, "I
understand
the benefits of globalization,
I desire the material prosperity that
may come with it,
but I know that in and of itself,
there has to be something more
in order to make life
worth living.
And what is more, that
as this globalization, which is in some ways
an impersonal force, changes and disrupts
people's lives,
so there is a
desire to reassert some sense of values,
some sense of shaping this process of globalization,
to ends that we consider
compatible with progress in humanity.
So I think
the interesting thing
in the end, as Miroslav was saying earlier,
and
Doug was remarking about
the point at which
people of religious faith come to it
a certain
common understanding--
the question that faith does ask about globalization,
and that should be asked; you don't have to be a
person of faith to ask it, incidentally--
but it is the question that faith asks of globalization,
is: to what purpose?
What is the end?
What are we trying to achieve here? And
without that,
it might be globalization
is a
poorer and possibly even
more dangerous
phenomenon.
So that's my
view of why this--
this matters,
and what we need to do
to make it--
to make it work.
And the conclusion, actually, that you come to
overall from this is,
the relationship between faith and globalization
is fundamentally important
and
in order for it to work,
the world of faith has got something to say
about this process--
not merely from the point of view of how we
avoid conflict between people of different
faiths,
but actually from the point of view of how
you make this process of globalization humane
and progressive, and
working for the benefit of all humankind.